[Musique]
ah ouais moi je vais vers
le milieu préféré et
dans cette situation qui est un petit
peu difficile pour moi j'ai besoin de me
ressourcer et de retrouver un peu
plaisir à la vie quoi
[Musique]
on a pas le choix en fait d'accepter ou
de refuser une classe donc on nous la
donne et puis on y va
[Musique]
j'ai eu un seul weekend pour préparer
mes cours dédié à un niveau précis et là
j'arrive en casse on me dit qu'en fait
quand il y aura des élèves
doubles niveau donc bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec toute la bonne volonté du monde je
me dis que ça va le faire et puis en
fait ça l'a passé du tout ou pas
j'avais l'impression de
[Musique]
relire le même cauchemar chaque jour
j'ai très vite compris qu'il fallait que
je me débrouille seul quoi si j'avais
pas eu cette vocation d'être professeur
je pense que j'aurais quitté le métier
[Musique]
le discours principal c'est j'en peux
plus je vais arrêter
[Musique]
c'est que il y a des conditions de
travail qui se dégradent on en demande
de plus en plus aux collègues qui sont
présents qui au bout d'un moment n'en
peuvent plus se mettre en arrêt et la
charge de travail revient sur les autres
et c'est un véritable Sarko vicieux nous
on ne cesse de le dénoncer mais pour
l'instant l'institution prend pas la
mesure de du mal-être dans l'éducation
nationale ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
c'est un exercice qui est extrêmement
important pour eux et pour nous pour
fidéliser en fait ces enseignants qui
sont une richesse pour pour l'académie
[Musique]
il peut y avoir des recrutements
dernière minute et là je le reconnais il
peut y avoir des loupés dans
l'accompagnement et il peut y avoir le
type de situation dont vous parlez
situation non seulement qui est
regrettable mais qui est pas acceptable
et sur lesquels on s'attache
véritablement à progresser
[Musique]
donc c'est bien un accompagnement et un
parcours de formation qui sont pensés de
manière systémique à la fois pour les
nouveaux enseignants mais également pour
ceux qui les accompagnent
des et de les amener enfin de les
intégrer dans un logique de
développement professionnel dans la
durée et de les amener si le souhaitent
vers la titularisation et vraiment de
les accompagner dans cette perspective
de concours et de titularisation
[Musique]